what's up you guys movie retrospective
time once again talking about brian de
palma some more we've been doing a lot
of brian de palma movies recently
they're good well yeah they're good i've
seen this one as a kid i forgot all
about it yeah i feel like this was on
cable a lot because i saw this probably
like younger than i should have seen it
because it's he just played it it's
pretty smutty yeah but uh yeah it was on
hbo cinemax something like that like all
the time in the early 1980s i feel like
and i probably saw it then although i
didn't really remember a lot of stuff
about it like i remember the poster and
i remembered like some of the stuff and
i remember like the big twist and
everything but a lot of it i had
forgotten so it was like really nice to
revisit it and it's actually like much
better than i remembered yeah well made
it is yeah i had somebody's you know
laughing at me because i said michael
caine was scary and like michael k scary
watch this [ __ ]
yeah he's in it michael can it's young
michael canton's looking handsome and
[ __ ] scary as [ __ ] scary
he was scary in the hand if you haven't
seen those movies you need to see him he
was kind of scary in the island even
though he was the good guy
it was just something intense about him
he always scared me as a kid when we
were watching this movie uh last night
you said to me that he's like you know
who uh michael caine looks like in this
movie particularly ted bundy yes he
looks just like he looked quite a bit
like ted bundy yeah and i don't know if
it was just the hair or because he had
kind of the same hair as ted bundy had
around the same time period his facial
expressions were looking like but yeah
so he did look this you know he said
look a little bit like that buddy
he does a great job in this uh yeah he's
really good in this i mean everybody is
good in this i feel like this movie so
this came out in 1980 yeah it stars that
girl from uh
the cop girl from uh robocop she's in it
she's nancy allen yeah she's wearing
damn
stockings and hoses and garters well
it's funny because i was i mean she was
in carrie as well and actually she was
married to brian de palma when for a
while like
for sure when this movie was made so
yeah so she was in she was in blowout
and stuff as well but yeah that's the
thing i was watching another review
earlier and like the guy was saying he's
like you know it's like i had only ever
seen nancy allen a robocop so i didn't
really get everybody talking about like
how sexy she was and everything yeah
watch this movie and then you'll
understand
she's like bo derek even hotter than bo
derek back in those days yeah it's me
and like i said you get to see her in
like really uh scanty clothes yeah i
remember you know people were crazy
about bo derek i didn't really see much
in her but you know i don't know
yeah but i i really like nancy allen
yeah honestly a lot better the thing
about dress to kill i kind of feel like
well you know and i think we brought
this up before but i think brian de
palma either you love him or you hate
him because he does have a very
distinctive style and i feel like some
people that don't care for him are just
like oh well he's just ripping off
hitchcock which
i guess is fair but i mean he doesn't
really make a secret of it though i mean
he's really really into hitchcock and i
mean dress to kill is essentially his
take on psycho like and there's stuff in
there that is absolutely inspired by
psycho and like i said he's not trying
to be slick about it or anything like
that he's basically saying i i really
like psycho and i'm making my own
version of it kind of and it's kind of
like a giallo movie kind of like it's
very very much like a giant movie i
liked it though yes i did it i yeah this
movie aged real well i mean other than
the whole like uh transgender thing but
the thing about it is that i kind of
feel like this movie does and obviously
this is going to have spoilers because
you know it's kind of hard to talk about
if you can't spoil what the big twist
ending is and honestly like seeing it
nowadays um it'll be pretty obvious i
feel like who the killer is because i
like i said i was watching another
review of it and the guy had never seen
it and didn't know uh anything about it
and he's like i knew who the killer was
like in the first five or ten minutes um
because they don't really make that much
of a secret about it
so you know so i'm saying it's probably
like easier to figure out nowadays but i
feel like this movie does
with like the same kind of thing that
silence of the lambs did were like the
where jamie gum was like supposed to be
like transgender or something like that
and they kind of made a big deal about
that i kind of feel like there's a weird
thing and this happened in giallo movies
too but there's not all of them but it
was like significant enough for me to
notice where it was always like the
killer they always had some kind of
weird psychosexual thing and it always
had and i guess it was more because
people didn't really understand like you
know transgender like what it was and
stuff so it seemed
weird or like exotic so it was just like
another thing to like shock the audience
with i guess it was real what real rare
back then
um well i don't know if it was it was
just rare to like people for people to
talk about it i guess yeah yeah there
were definitely fewer of them though
i mean you know there are photographs of
them going back to the 20s but there
were i think there were fewer of them uh
just because
jet if you didn't live in a big city you
couldn't get away with that they'd kill
you
well that's what i'm saying i i kind of
feel like i don't think that i don't
think that it was necessarily rarer it's
just that there weren't the outlets like
you know you couldn't get so in some
ways i feel like this movie coming out
of 1980 even though i think it even it
got some criticism at the time for
implying that and i don't think it
necessarily implied this um but for
implying that like transgender people
were like weird or weird lunatics or
murderers or something like that but the
thing about it too is that it also
seemed to have
i mean there was a clip in there of
nancy hunt who was a pretty well-known
like transgender and uh she was on the
phil donahue show like from the late 70s
or something like that so it seemed like
they were trying and they kind of like
explained like how stuff was done which
is kind of funny nowadays because i feel
like a lot of people know that but it
was really kind of like delving into a
lot of issues that really didn't get
into and i think that he really
brian de palma he this is basically like
i said it's his take on psycho and
psycho norman bates was not transgender
but he dressed up like his mom so you
could say that was transvestism sort of
like a weird kind of trans
transvesticism dude
these old movies uh uh i think uh they
they
they would equate or they would draw
parallels between like gender dysphoria
and multiple personality that's what
this one does i feel like more yeah yeah
and in a case you know in defense of
silence of the labs
um
dr electra said that that james gum that
he wasn't a trans did he wasn't a real
one that he was just person yeah i was
gonna say that yeah and he was actually
a serial killer he was killing
transgender people
um
he just thought he was a transgender
um and this movie kind of
says that too they were saying that he
was more like multiple personalities
yeah this seemed more like a multiple
personality yeah
he had a male personality and a female
personality and when the male
personality would get
a
[ __ ] randy the female personality
would have would emerge and try to uh
stop what was happening and kill the
woman so it wasn't it wasn't
transsexualism it was multiple
personality more anything else yeah more
of a line like and like i said so i i
feel like for 1980 i mean this was i
don't know you could say it was kind of
ahead of its time for 1980 like it just
in the fact that it was so frank and
talking about it
and but i don't know like i said brian
de palma this is basically
psycho but
in 1980 and also like a giallo movie and
also kind of brian de palma i feel like
he always had a little bit
a little bit camp a little bit of a
sense of humor
a little bit i mean he's a lot more like
his stylistic uh stuff is i think what a
lot of people really like about him and
it's great in this i mean some of the
shots in this he does his uh you know
kind of his standard shots were like
split split screen he's got a couple of
those in here not that as many as some
of his other movies but he has that
thing and i wish i could remember the
word for it i heard the word for it like
i heard somebody that was like a
filmmaker say what it was called but i
can't remember what it is where there's
like something in the foreground like
focused in the foreground and then
there'd be something focused in the
background but so like both things are
in focus but then it's kind of like
fuzzy in the middle and i can't remember
like what the word for that is there is
a word for it but he uses that a lot and
he uses that a lot in this as well and
it looks really cool like i really like
that i actually kind of misspoke
he wasn't killing transsexuals and
sounds like lambs because that head in
the jar wasn't a transsexual that guy
was looking for a transsexual and found
found jam gum that's how that [ __ ] went
down yeah he was killing women because
he wanted their skin he just killed
straight women he wanted their skin and
he would kill he killed that occasional
uh guy who
you know was looking for a transsexual
but the guy was but elektra said he was
not transsexual yeah that he wasn't that
he wasn't a real one he just wanted to
be one right and then he wanted to be a
woman and he wanted to transform into
something else but he wasn't transacting
he was a serial killer yeah and like you
said i think in in dress to kill they
kind of equate
being trans with being
having multiple personality or having
like a dual personality or split
personality type of thing
but you know it was just that one just
just just yeah i never really got the
impression that they were saying that
all people and i think that's like the
the clip that they showed of nancy hunt
like on the phil donahue show which uh i
guess like the doctor was watching it um
does kind of like go a long way towards
saying yeah we know people like that are
just like regular people yeah
like we're not saying that they're we're
not saying that they're serial killers
right but yeah but the way that one guy
described it he said he said he
described it he was actually describing
multiple personality to sword or not
yeah like he had two identities two
identities that were fighting for
control because apparently i mean like i
said spoiler alert uh for a movie that's
you know more than
how old is this
more than 40 years old yeah um you know
a spoiler alert for that but yeah
michael kane is the killer but the thing
about it is and like i said if you see
the beginning if you're looking really
close you can probably tell even though
he's uh you know dressed like a woman
but
i kind of feel like yeah it had to be
some kind of like real strict split
personality because he apparently had a
very successful like psychiatric
practice and nobody really suspected
that he was uh murdering people
now i don't know if he had just started
murdering people he wasn't murdering
people the female personality bobby was
the name of the
female personality i think it's more
than that yeah it's split personality i
mean they do mention transgender on the
show and like i said they do have a
weird scene at the end where nancy allen
is talking to keith gordon about um
where their characters are are talking
about how they do sex changes and stuff
like that and this like old lady at this
other table at the restaurant is looking
on horrified which i thought was kind of
funny but uh that's what i mean there's
kind of like funny scenes in this but
yeah so
uh so yeah this is basically it's set up
almost exactly like psycho i feel like
even down to because you know how in
psycho very famously you had like you
know janet lee and she was supposedly
like the star of the movie but then she
gets killed like 40 minutes in or
something like that
same thing happens in this they set up
angie dickinson's character kate
at the beginning as the main character
and spend a lot of time with her and
[ __ ] like that and then she gets off 35
minutes in
and then it goes on to nancy allen's
character so that's almost the exact
same thing that psycho did and there's
even like a shower scenes and there's a
scene at the very end which i'm not
entirely sure had to be there or not but
the scene at the very end which is like
a dream sequence but it's almost like
the end of carrie so that's almost like
he's parodying himself a little bit
so there was that but so what happens
your fault like angie dickinson
plays kate and she's kind of middle-aged
i think she was 48 when she made this
movie and um
at the very beginning i mean this movie
like starts out she looks great too that
well the body double that wasn't her
that wasn't her no it was a that was the
um all right because that was going boy
the penthouse
whatever the [ __ ] they called it the
penthouse of the year of 1977 or
something yeah because i was going well
48 man she's sucking looking great 48.
yeah so that yeah because the scene like
18. they showed they show her naked at
the beginning it's it's good how it's
done though because from the in the long
shots it absolutely does look like angie
dickinson's face and they i don't think
they had the technology back then to
like composite somebody else's head on
somebody else's body which you could do
easily nowadays but yeah i was i was
gonna say like um yeah because there's a
shower scene at the beginning she's in
the shower her husband is like standing
at the bathroom shaving and there's like
a very long extended sequence of you
know close-ups of her rubbing soap over
her nipples and like down in her pubes
and everything like that
well no i'm just saying it's like it's
kind of hard not to
it's like right there up in your face
she's like watching her husband shaving
like yeah that's right and it goes on
for like a really really long time and
then there's like a thing i don't i
don't think this necessarily counts as a
dream sequence at the beginning it was
more like a fantasy like she was having
a sexual fantasy because there's this
weird thing where she's like watching
her husband shaving and like kind of
getting herself off in the shower and
then like somebody like another dude
like appears in the shower and like
grabs her from behind yeah she was seven
rape fantasies i think it was yeah so it
was kind of that but then we see
afterward like the reality where like
her husband is just laying on top of her
like moving all awkward and like being
yeah
stuff like that so and then she goes to
her to michael caine's character dr
elliott who is her psychiatrist and is
basically talking about what a lousy lay
her husband is and she's really kind of
um you know frustrated and all this
other kind of [ __ ] and she even like
comes on to him a little bit like
low-key
and uh which you know that's what gets
her killed in the end because you know
because she she got like she she made it
she got him around yeah she goes down to
the damn
uh [ __ ] art gallery to try to pick up
dudes
she gets one too and uh they hook up
that's not like that a lot of people
talk about like that sequence because
it's such a good it's like it's nine or
ten minutes of basically her and this
dude and they don't talk yeah they're
just it's almost kind of like this weird
like flirty like trying to get this dude
to [ __ ] make a move
he's not really making a move it takes a
while he eventually [ __ ] grabs it but
they're like chasing each other through
the museum and stuff and she's just like
where's that dick i'm trying to jump on
it yeah
she's trying to like not ask for it
[Laughter]
so she jumps into the damn taxi and he
gets in there after and then [ __ ] he
knocks her down in a taxi and a cab
driver's watching he's just like he's
watching later she turns up dead in the
[ __ ] cab driver's like yeah i saw the
whole thing he's back there [ __ ]
cracking the hell up
like you know
he's in the cab and everything after
[ __ ] wedding ring got lost wasn't
that in the cab no the wedding ring
actually because they went back to the
guy's apartment yeah remember like
because they [ __ ] in the cab and then
he's like well now we're coming back to
your house and they never talk like they
never talk to one another they make you
think that that was the killer
they do kind of and well everybody kind
of looked the same in the 70s with those
smoked sunglasses yeah it turns out he
was he he was just he just gave her what
she wanted yeah but then so so the thing
about it she goes back to his apartment
he's worried about
well yeah because she didn't get that
though she was just worried about it
though did she well no she got killed
before but no remember she was looking
at a piece no no i was just going to
tell you i was just going to tell you
oh so she's at the apartment and she
banged the dude yeah and stayed there
and then she's like oh [ __ ] i gotta go
home and then she's looking for
something like looking for some paper or
something to like leave him a note and
sees this big long letter that from the
doctor being like hey you have i think
it said that he had syphilis and
gonorrhea yeah she had it no that he had
it the guy she just slept with oh okay
how would it how did she get that
it was on the doctors would send if you
have like a sexually transmitted disease
they will usually tell you it's like hey
you might want to tell all your sex
partners right that you have a sexually
transmitted disease so they can get
tested so she was like looking for some
paper in the drawer and she saw the
letter from the doctor that said hey the
guy whose name was warren or something
like that um you know you have i think
it was syphilis and gonorrhea so he's so
he's been picking up ladies like at the
met for a long time even though that
wasn't it's supposed to be the met but
it was actually yeah yeah party didn't
understand how did he how did he know
where she was
what are you talking about oh man
how did i watch the damn movie and
jenny's thinking that i don't know what
i'm talking about well
the dude that she's screwed in the ho in
the taxi cab right
how did he send her a letter saying he
didn't send her a letter the doctor sent
him a letter and it was in his drawer in
his desk in his apartment him the dude
that she slept with
how did she find it she was looking
remember she was looking for paper so
she could write a nice note like oh you
know i'm going to leave my phone that's
right she that was that was his
apartment yeah okay they went back to
his apartment she's married and has a
teenage kid they're not going to go back
to her place i thought she just went
back to her place no no no i don't
remember i didn't remember the part that
she went i thought they just did that in
the taxi and that was it no then they
went to because remember no she was in
that's how she ended up getting killed
because she was in his apartment
building okay that's where she was she
wasn't at home she's at her own home no
because she has a husband and a kid
she's not going to go back to her house
yeah they would
no i'm just i'm just okay
no i'm just saying that that's not what
happened in the movie though that's not
out of the movie she went back to this
guy's house and she was like oh i'm
gonna get the [ __ ] out while he's still
sleeping i got you and she was looking
for paper for a note about where she was
no and then she and then she looked for
paper for a note and then like she saw a
letter that the doctor had sent to him
at some point in the past yeah he was
saying that you had and it's like hey
you might want to inform like your sex
partners and she was like oh [ __ ]
and then she goes to the elevator and
then she realizes she left her wedding
ring and then she went back
and that's when she got killed like she
was in the elevator and then the person
came and the reason that she got killed
was
like i said spoiler alert because
michael caine's the killer but it's
michael kane and drag michael kane
wanted to kill her because she turned
him on and he was
like i said he would dissociate and go
into his female persona
when a woman like aroused his male
persona because he wanted to like cut
that [ __ ] off right
so uh so she turned him on so he had
been following her
yeah he had been following her so um so
when she got into the elevator uh he
like slashed her up and then at that
point like so she gets killed
and then at that point nancy allen who
is a prostitute and has been visiting
another client in the same building
she happened to be going down and she
saw
the murder like she didn't see it
actually take place but she saw the
aftermath the aftermath and she saw the
killer like in the mirror she's just a
prostitute she's a [ __ ] high class
[ __ ] yeah she was like a high
high-class escort and she had a lot of
money she had like a really nice
department and they had her talking on
the phone about like buying stocks and
she was like investing in art and stuff
like that so
she was looking out for her future so
yeah so she was like a very very high
class like escort but she's a great
character in this i really really like
her so yeah so after angie dickinson who
you think is going to be like the main
character she gets killed
and then it goes to nancy allen
who
saw the murder
and the cops also make her think because
she kind of stupidly like picks up the
straight razor you know like in the
thing and it's just kind of like hey
call the cops or whatever so her
fingerprints are all over it and uh the
cops actually like end up telling her
hey well you're a suspect for this
because you were there and like your
fingerprints were on the thing they
didn't really believe that but you don't
find that until later um so
she's basically like you have 48 hours
to kind of
uh figure out like who really did this
or help out in the investigation like
otherwise we're putting you in jail
because you're a suspect and also dennis
franz like playing the inspector or
detective or whatever he's great in this
too and he's always just like
yelling at her like for being a
prostitute he's like not really
believing anything she says or anything
but like i said
as the movie goes on you do actually
find out the cops were taking her
seriously they were just like busting
her balls the whole time which seemed a
little shitty but you know but yeah so
after that like nancy allen's character
his name is liz actually
and she teams up
with
um
angie dickinson's character whose name
is kate
her teenage son who's played by keith
gordon who if you didn't recognize him
he played arnie in uh christine i think
he was in legend of billie jean too
i didn't realize this but he became a
director later on yeah he's good in this
movie i like i always liked him a lot he
was the dude that played arnie and
[ __ ] christine right and i'm watching
him and i was like man that would make a
really good paula tradies back in the
old dune movie
i think he'd make a good paul tradies
yeah i was i always liked him as an
actor yeah he was in a lot of stuff in
the 80s i think he was in back to school
with ryder dangerfield too reason being
is because uh if you ever read the
books and everything and then you find
out what happens later to [ __ ] paul
paul had a [ __ ] sinister side to him
he ended up basically becoming [ __ ]
totalitarian
religious maniac kinda
and he had a weird quality well this guy
has a weird quality to him he kind of
slightly sinister and he's like a
sinister nerd
he always struck me that way you know i
mean he'd make a good paul trainees well
i think that's what i liked so much
about him and christine was that he was
totally believable as like a real dorky
outcast and then like when he went all
sinister he was totally believable as
being a sinister menacing
dude as well like he was he had a really
good range in that way yeah he could do
he could do both at the same time if he
wanted to yeah
although in this one um he's just he's
nerdy like he's like a science nerd and
stuff but he's a he's a good guy i mean
he's a really good guy and he's like
really upset about uh his mother dying
obviously uh step dad doesn't really
seem to give two shits about it but he
basically is like starts using kind of
his scientific knowledge
uh to help liz the prostitute they're
gonna figure out like who the killer is
like who killed his mom and he's in awe
of her because she's just a [ __ ] hot
piece and [ __ ] she's real intelligent
he's just like wow yeah i like the real
i like the rapport they have before that
it's like it's not super believable but
like i said there's a lot of stuff in
this movie that probably isn't super
believable but it's just kind of like a
giallo movie there's a lot of stuff that
happens in there that's not super
believable either but it's just you're
watching it just because it's fun and
stylish and you know you just people get
chopped up and there's all kind of like
cool shots and [ __ ] like that it's just
fun it's just a fun like erotic thriller
slash giallo slash hitchcock homage i
guess but yeah so keith gordon's there
like he's got this great thing where he
figures out like
he goes to the dude's office because
they figure out okay well whoever the
killer is um is one of dr elliott's
patience because they kind of like try
to throw you a red herring by showing dr
elliott michael caine's character
getting a phone call from bobby um
basically admitting to the murder saying
yeah i put on like women's clothes and i
stole your straight razor like from your
office and killed that lady it's gonna
be in the paper and blah blah blah so
they're trying to like throw you off
like it's two different people so you're
thinking that um that the killer is
actually a patient of his and he
actually acts like that too because
apparently he's completely dissociated
from his other from his female persona
so like when she's off doing stuff he
doesn't really seem to be aware of it so
like i said it's much more like a
multiple personality thing than you know
like a transgender thing i would think
but yeah so they borrowed that [ __ ] from
[ __ ] well i couldn't say they bought it
from childhood giallo barter from other
stuff that was in all those movies at
that time
there was like and i said men i
mentioned earlier a lot of giallo movies
have that as well yeah well and i don't
even like i said i don't even think it
was necessarily it was just kind of like
one it was a way to reveal something
because it was shocking and two because
it was like a twist that you didn't
expect yeah you weren't supposed to
expect it oh she was a she was a boy the
whole time i didn't know you know that
kind of [ __ ] yeah and i kind of feel
like that's what they were just
basically doing it as kind of like i
don't know it's kind of like a way to
make it seem like michael caine wasn't
the killer the whole time but but like i
said because michael caine
is not
let's not get a lie and not all that
feminine looking so even when they so
even when they put him in a wig and a
hat even if you can't necessarily tell
it's michael kane you can tell that
that's not a woman you know what i mean
so i kind of feel like especially i
don't know so i feel like maybe back
then like people in bed because
everybody in the movie in the context of
the movie is like i saw a woman like in
the elevator and clearly the audience is
supposed to think it's a woman but um
it's obviously not it doesn't look like
a woman it doesn't look like a woman
you know
so so then you're just kind of like well
that's obviously a dude but i like i
said like a lot of you know a lot of
diallo movies did that too back in those
days maybe people would have been fooled
because it wasn't as common to see a man
dressed up as a woman but you know so
maybe they may especially if you were
younger so maybe you know but to me i
look at a good that's a dude that's what
i'm saying so so i feel like even people
if people see it nowadays even if they
don't recognize that that's michael
caine they'll be like well that's
that's obviously a man you know what i
mean like it's not a woman but you know
so it's not like a big huge shock but
uh but that said i don't know i just i
kind of feel like like i said this is
very very much like psycho
and there's even a scene
you know like it has a shower it
actually has two shower scenes because
the one at the end like with nancy allen
uh because she yeah she's naked in that
too i thought it was just i thought it
was just the lingerie but i guess she's
naked in the shower scene at the end too
but uh yeah so they have that long
extended shower scene which is great but
it turns out to be a dream which
okay but it's like i said the kind the
end of it was kind of gave me a little
bit of a carry vibe
but uh you know there there's that kind
of like i don't know that whole dream
sequence at the end i'm i like it but i
don't know if it necessarily had to be
there because i kind of feel like it
should have ended
where psycho ended because they had
pretty much the analogous scene as
psycho had where you had the other
uh psychiatrist dr levy in there like
explaining the pathology of michael
caine's character saying oh well you
know uh
he had this dual personality and blah
blah and had this female side and you
know so anything any woman that aroused
his male side was going to like bring
out the female side and like had to kill
it because she wanted to get a sex
change and like she couldn't get
permission and all this other kind of
stuff so like i said so that's almost
kind of like what they did later on in
silence of the lambs but yeah so that
was kind of like the same scene as
psycho too where they had the guy having
to explain
why norman bates like dress up like his
mom like to kill people because he was
replacing her essentially so
it's similar
yeah well yeah because it's a similar
kind of thing well yeah because i mean
the book psycho uh you know the robert
block novel that the movie was based on
that's who he uh that's who inspired
norman bates even though there's a lot
different yeah
doing the same kind of stuff though
putting on what he was putting on
women's skin too
well yeah i mean that's the thing yeah
he's weird i don't know if you could
have got away with that in 1960
but uh
but you know what i mean i mean there
was some like splatter in the mid-60s
but i don't know but yeah so i don't
know like
if you haven't seen i feel like this is
maybe one of
bryan de palma made so many good movies
though and i think we talked about that
before like we just talked about the
untouchables the other day and we just
talked about like a bunch of films that
he did like i said i know he's kind of
like love it or hate it because some
people think that you know it's too over
the top or it's too
um earth's style over substance or it's
all hitchcock rip-offs or something like
that and i think that's kind of like
unfair you could kind of say the same
thing about jalan movies like i said
because a lot of those were real into
hitchcock and [ __ ] like that too so and
dario argento was like a massive massive
fan of hitchcock and a lot of his stuff
was very hitchcocky and also so i don't
think brian de palma is doing anything
that other filmmakers aren't doing they
all they're all kind of doing that right
yes me department's looking he delivered
on this one
yeah i really really liked this movie i
had forgotten how how good this was it's
it's just a great looking movie it's
just i don't know it's a lot of fun
even though the mystery at the heart of
it isn't all that mysterious like by
today's standards like you could
probably figure it out like pretty early
but that's it doesn't matter like
because you're just so engaged with the
characters and you know and a lot of the
scenes like there's that great scene in
the museum like early on there's that
great scene like where nancy allen is
like running through the subway uh you
know the subway station and then the
subway train like with the guys chasing
her and then the killer comes in the
other side and like you know [ __ ]
keith gordon like maces her or whatever
and there's all that so there's all
these really really good like sequences
in it and just the way it's shot he
always he just has such a great visual
style too like we talked about that a
lot with uh blowout which was another
one that we just talked about recently
it's good storytelling yeah i mean this
just like a really fun like erotic
thriller from the early 1980s so i mean
if you're into brian to palm at all if
you liked carrie or if you liked any of
that kind of stuff then i mean this i
think this is definitely like a good one
to watch it's not
super it's not
like a giallo in the sense that it's
like super super violent with a high
body count
but i mean you know angie
angie dickinson gets chopped up pretty
uh graphically in the beginning like not
graphic by today's standards but by 1980
standards it was pretty graphic and then
but after that it's more like a cat and
mouse like a chase kind of thing because
then the killer kind of targets uh nancy
allen's character liz because she you
know saw him and is trying to figure out
like who he is so and also she turned
him on too so you know so the killer's
chasing her as well so it's more of that
kind of thing like it's a more chase
like a murder mystery like they're
trying to like a whodunit kind of it's
more like that kind of thing than a
giallo but i guess jealous are kind of
like that too but yeah so this is
definitely if you like giallo movies if
you like brian de palma's other movies
and you haven't seen this one for
whatever reason then this is definitely
definitely a good one i think it's
probably one of my favorite de palma
movies i haven't seen them all
admittedly but i really really like this
one because you guys know i love jlo
movies and this is kind of like
has that same kind of vibe to it so i we
tried i was going to watch this on hbo
max or on amazon prime and it said no
you needed like the showtime add-on and
it was like 10 bucks but at least if
you're in the us it's free on 2b at
least as of this recording because i was
like this better be free somewhere
because i don't like i don't have a lot
of money so yeah so uh but yeah it's on
to be pretty sure i think it might also
be on roku channel if you want to watch
it on there but yeah uh really really
fun movie dress to kill from 1980 uh
please tell us what you thought about it
in the comments and that will do it for
this movie retrospective we will see you
guys again on the next one bye